[Music]
it's super musically super musically
okay it sounded like you said super
musically oh it's super music glee that
is what I said make you glad you came
yes some of your favorite Gleeks are
reuniting for the flash and Supergirl
musical crossover on the CW and only et
was on set for the dreamy experience can
we get a little spin this is our first
day shooting any of the musical like
dream sequence dream world scenes at all
we've gone back in time as you can see
uh and we're in this beautiful theater
Berrien cara or stuck in a dream world
and having to figure out shenanigans oh
they're on a journey they're both on
personal journeys figuring things out
together as a team action what do we do
now what do we think this musikmeister
needs us to do now ah now this isn't the
first time the fastest man alive and the
Girl of Steel have teamed up together
but it is the first time they're singing
together and to make things super
exciting their duet was written by
fellow CW star Rachel bloom I love grant
and he's such a good dancer and I knew
we were gonna have fun but then when I
found out it was Rachel bloom that was
even more exciting I have friends I
definitely have friends I'm your super
friend your super friend and the stars
confess that they were having some major
days on Glee vibes during rehearsal it's
kind of a similar glyph fashion to what
I'd done back in the day we're like
yesterday we did an hour and a half tap
rehearsal and now we're shooting it
today yeah and I didn't know they told
me they were like you were shooting this
tomorrow isn't it what are you shooting
tomorrow yeah okay quick it feels really
familiar rehearsing the song we win
granted I rehearse the song and learn to
dance I was like oh man those were such
good times it's crazy it has for me at
least been like riding a bike kind of
where like you my feet are realizing
what the sequence is before like my
brain is like this do this so I'm like a
feeder like no I'm good bro chill I got
it I'll be there in a flash Barry that
was funny and you were singing live up
there a little bit yeah well yeah we're
like got the flip track and we like sing
on top of it so it looks like it's live
yeah we're singing for real I love this
time period of the music that we're
getting sings so I'm in heaven in the
first place
we're not faking it we're actually this
is a real background all of us are
really trained in musical theater so
it's a real musical episode follow the
script although I should mention we
dying here you can die out there
I miss being bulletproof
[Music]
you